this is the mess just mess up where is
the poorest dirtiest most depressing
slum in the world in Haiti India Africa
is that what this is no I'm in America
one of the richest parts of America
highest rents in all of America this is
San Francisco today encampments of
street people everywhere some pitched
tents planning to stay a long time some
have mental problems vampires are real
and I'm paranoid as all hell other
street people complain about them they
run around and they shout at themselves
they make it bad for people like us that
hang out with a sign some people shoot
up in plain sight it's nasty seeing
somebody a shooter right there
police don't do anything about it
they'll get somebody for drinking a beer
but they'll walk right past people using
needles every day in San Francisco an
average of 85 cars are broken into
they're called smash-and-grabs
Inside Edition left things in a car to
test how long they'd last not long watch
as these Bonnie and Clyde wannabes
stroll up and peer inside our car they
wait here for the sidewalk to clear then
the thief throws up his hood since store
owners can't rely on city cops to deal
with the masses of homeless some hire
private police to patrol around their
stores
Cody Clements works this neighborhood a
lot of times because somebody who pays
for our service calls and says hey
there's a homeless group of people
setting up a camp in front of my
business or my residents can you come
ask them to move there used to be
hundreds of private cops like Cody but
then San Francisco's police union
complained now there are fewer than 10
left I just have you guys stand up for
me Cody offers help to people living on
the streets but most turn it down well
gene type of homeless outreach services
or anything
San Francisco is generous it offers
street people food stamps free shelter
train tickets and $70 a month in cash I
don't use any resources but there
they're always offering resources to San
Francisco it's just a good place to hang
out like many these two come here from
out of town
do you like the lifestyle of course I do
as you just heard they love the freedom
of not having to follow the rules so the
homeless stay in the streets and every
day new people arrive some residents
want the city to get tougher with people
living on the streets skip them to the
point where they have to make a decision
between jail and rehab and there's a way
we can do that other cities do it but
for some reason San Francisco doesn't
have the political will to San
Francisco's politicians have promised to
fix the homeless problem they've
promised that for decades if there is a
problem involved in housing a
homelessness you don't do something
about it as part of the city's program
the homeless were to be temporarily
housed in hotels thousand units right
here in the Tenderloin we have already
moved six thousand eight hundred and
sixty human beings so we need to fund
programs like homeward bound but the
extra funding hasn't worked the number
of street people has grown most every
year one reason is that even if some of
these people wanted to get off the
street to rent an apartment there aren't
many apartments available most of San
Francisco looks like this three-story
buildings maybe two apartments per
building you can't add on to that it's
illegal because of that housing that
exists costs a fortune this doesn't look
like an expensive neighborhood but these
houses sell for millions of dollars
millions of dollars what if I come in
and I bought this property and I want to
put up an apartment building it would
house a bunch of people yeah it's your
bad Lora foots nonprofit runs ads that
try to convince residents to allow
bigger buildings to say yummy yes in my
backyard but good luck with that
even in liberal San Francisco people
don't want that I would hate it I would
hate it I think it'd be really congested
where will people live I'm not sure
you're a builder go build stuff let me
build John Dennis has been trying to
replace this grimy old building this has
been a defunct meatpacking plant it's
been empty for at least 15 years he
wants to turn this into this which would
house 60 people but it's taken four
years just to get permission to build
and all that time we're paying property
taxes and we're paying for maintenance
of the building people in San Francisco
often claim to be all about helping the
poor but their policies make life
tougher for the poor what's your next
project in San Francisco no more
projects in San Francisco I'm done I'll
never do another project here